bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france alors qu'elle est
aujourd'hui l'impact de la crise du
coronavirus sur le marché de la location
et plus généralement sur le logement à
paris d'abord malheureusement beaucoup
de locataires se trouve aujourd'hui dans
une difficulté à payer leur loyer
notamment ceux qui sont les plus
modestes et ceux qui vivent en logement
social et pour ce qui concerne ces
catégories là je rappelle que 1
parisiens sur quatre vit en logement
social nous avons mis en place des
mesures de soutien d'accompagnement pour
faire en sorte qu'elles ne tombent pas
en situation d'impayés et puis le
deuxième impact c'est celui dont vous
venez de parler dans le secteur privé
c'est que beaucoup de logements qui
avaient été transformés en logements
airbnb ces dernières années sont
désormais vides et la question qui se
pose à nous comme collectivité
parisienne c'est comment nous pouvons
faire en sorte que ces logements
redevienne utile aux parisiens et
permettent de loger des parisiens qui
sont là toute l'année et non pas des
touristes et vous songez banque a
racheté certains de ces logements airbnb
vous essayez on le sait depuis longtemps
à la mairie de paris de diminuer le
nombre de locations de courte durée est
ce que finalement la crise sanitaire ne
tombe pas plutôt à pic pour votre projet
ce qui est sûr c'est que nous avons une
opportunité historique de reprendre le
contrôle de ces logements on a vu ces
logements touristiques pullulent et un
peu partout dans paris notamment dans
les quartiers les plus touristiques les
plus historiques je pense au centre de
paris je pense à montmartre et comme ses
logements sont désormais vides comme
leurs propriétaires n'arrivent plus à
les louer à des touristes et que cette
crise du tourisme va durer un certain
temps nous avons effectivement la
possibilité de faire en sorte qu'ils
reviennent en location traditionnelle et
que dans ces logements on puisse avoir
demain des parisiens qui seront logés là
et loger toute l'année cela passe par
notamment le rachat que nous envisageons
d'un certain nombre de ces logements
notamment pour des propriétaires qui
avaient contracté des prêts qu'ils
comptaient sur une rentabilité
airbnb très forte et qui vont se
retrouver en situation de défaillance
c'est à dire qu'ils n'auront plus la
possibilité
rembourser leurs prêts faute de
touristes cela nous envisageons
effectivement de les racheter
quel serait le bénéfice financier pour
les futurs locataires à quel sera le
profil des locataires prio terre si vous
parvenez donc à racheter ces logements
airbnb l'idée pour nous c'est de faire
ce qu'on appelle du logement
intermédiaire c'est-à-dire du logement
20% en dessous du prix de marché du
logement destiné aux familles de la
classe moyenne
voyez on a quand même dû traverser une
crise au cours de laquelle on a vu à
quel point il est nécessaire par exemple
de loger des soignants de loger ces
classes moyennes qui ont fait tourner la
ville qui ont fait tourner le pays
pendant cette période si compliqué et
bien si ces logements permettait de
loger ces catégories là ce serait je
crois une très très très bonne nouvelle
et donc nous souhaitons il travaille et
je note par ailleurs que de manière
naturelle sans que nous ayons besoin de
les racheter un certain nombre de ces
logements depuis maintenant quelques
semaines sont à nouveau loué par leurs
propriétaires sur des périodes plus
longues que de la location touristique
donc ça se fait de manière naturelle
puis nous souhaitons encourager ce
phénomène entre ses dents à des rachats
mais malgré ça il va falloir quand même
convaincre certains propriétaires de
céder leur logement à quel prix pour la
mairie de paris
combien ont racheté ce que vous avez
davantage de détails à nous donner pas
encore nous allons créer dans les
semaines qui viennent une une société
foncière qui sera justement dédiée aux
rachats d'appartement ou d'immeubles
pour remettre ces logements location à
destination des classes moyennes donc
nous donnerons davantage de précisions
dans les semaines et les mois à venir
mais enfin en tout cas la volonté
politique elle est là nous traversons un
moment particulier puis vous savez cette
crise sanitaire elle va durer et je ne
pense pas que les gens aient très envie
dans les semaines et les mois à venir de
voir débarquer des tas de touristes dans
leur copropriété des gens venus parfois
de l'autre bout du monde et donc on a
besoin
d'intervenir sur ce secteur à la fois
pour des raisons sanitaires et puis
aussi pour garantir le droit au logement
de tad catégorie qui s'en trouvait privé
à cause du développement de ces
locations touristiques
mais ce que vous ne craignez pas aussi
une baisse du nombre de touristes due à
la réduction de l'offre airbnb à paris
de toute façon il y aura une diminution
du nombre de touristes dans les semaines
et les mois à venir et cette crise du
tourisme sera vraisemblablement assez
durable les acteurs du tourisme le
disent d'ailleurs ce que nous avons dit
nous depuis le départ c'est que paris
est bien sûr une ville touristique mais
que ce développement du tourisme ne doit
pas se faire au détriment de la qualité
de vie des habitants et donc nous ne
pouvons pas accepter que des logements
qui auparavant étaient des logements
habités par des gens qui étaient là à
l'année deviennent des hôtels
clandestins et donc nous avons là
l'opportunité de remettre la main sur
ces logements est de faire en sorte
qu'ils profitent à nouveau à des à des
parisiens donc le touriste ne oui mais
pas à n'importe quelle condition
merci beaucoup ils aiment leur femme
mère habitant logement de la ville
d'auch pareil